I predicted the collapse of this billion
dollar company that went bankrupt today
and I'm going to show you how I shot an
entire video about it predicting it
yesterday and it was supposed to come
out yesterday but it decided hey these
are Big allegations I should give them a
chance to respond for comments
which was a huge mistake basically I
emailed them I said hey I think you're
lying I think you're insolvent I have a
lot of reasons for thinking so and I'm
gonna do a story about it in 24 hours
and a few hours later Genesis did
respond all right but not to me they
responded to their clients they had a
call with them at 7am basically saying
hey uh oops we've been lying for the
entire week we don't have the money
after all now uh honestly from my
perspective it's been difficult to not
see this is like them front running the
story although being objective about
this it's probably pure coincidence
because I wasn't the only one talking
about this and this is a billion dollar
company it's hard to believe they'd
spend their time watching coffeezilla
but I'm just gonna say I am biased on
this one because I sent them an email
and like and then right after that they
admit they don't have the money so
that's just my bias I wanted to let you
guys know that ahead of time either way
I guess I'm just upset that this video
didn't come out before their collapsed
like it was supposed to because that was
supposed to be the point of all this I
will say though if you're following me
on Twitter I did warn you guys ahead of
time five days ago to take your money
out of Gemini earn today Jim and I
earned did pause withdrawals because of
this Genesis story we're about to talk
about so I know I was able to warn some
people I just wish I was able to warn
more people and today I just want to
show you the video of me predicting the
collapse of Genesis obviously at this
point it is too late but I think it's a
super interesting time capsule because
while in hindsight it's obvious
beforehand there were serious red flags
so I have not added anything to
yesterday's video because I wanted to
leave it exactly as is and here's that
story here's me predicting it it was
supposed to be called The Fallout of FTX
[Music]
all right the Fallout of FTX has been
horrific they owe between 10 to 50
billion dollars according to bankruptcy
filings and could owe up to a million
people money that they do not have
meanwhile their CEO is busy on Twitter
trolling people saying what Believe It
or Not these cryptic tweets are some of
our only Communications from the world's
most formerly generous billionaire well
that in a New York Times interview where
he told them quote you would have
thought I'd be getting no sleep right
now and instead I'm getting some it
could be worse oh man where would we be
without the hard-hitting questions of
the New York Times millions are
suffering but at least Sam is sleeping
soundly but it's not even just Sam's
direct victims that I want to talk about
today nearly everything besides Sam's
sleep schedule have been affected crypto
as a whole faces existential risk as
people lose trust in Magic internet
money but there's also an indirect risk
of all these companies that loaned SBF
money now some of the lenders could be
going bankrupt as well and this is what
we call contagion it's like when you
have a nuclear blast you have the
immediate Direct Hit the explosion
itself but then there's also radiation
it's slower sometimes invisible at first
but it hurts more people and we've
already seen signs of contagion coming
from companies like block fight earlier
this week they paused withdrawals citing
significant exposure to FTX there's also
other companies like salt lending who
also paused withdrawals for the same
problems and this is what contagion
looks like when other companies face
troubles because of one company going
under and I think it's important to
report on companies that fall apart and
explain like what happened but
unfortunately it's already too late to
save anyone on blockfi or salt Because
by the time a company has paused
withdrawals it's too late all you can do
is is pray they come back so today I
want to talk about a company that it's
not too late for a company that hasn't
gone bust yet and I want to warn people
ahead of time but I want to emphas size
that this is a theory and their
Financial Health could be better or
worse than I know I'm just sharing my
opinion based on the facts that are
available so let's talk about Genesis
now many of you might not recognize the
name but they're huge lenders in crypto
who at one point had 4 -5 billion
Target retail Traders like everyday
people like you and me instead they
worked with other institutions so if
you're thinking well okay that just
means I'm not affected right well don't
be so sure even if you've never heard of
these guys specifically you could have
had money with them for example let's
say you had your money in the gemiini
earn program which advertises eight
percent on your crypto if you leave it
in the hands of the social network
rowing team now you might think this is
a great deal you see the Winkle Twins
and decide finally someone you can trust
right or at least someone you can
backstab but the problem you might not
see is that you're not just trusting
Gemini you're also trusting the people
they lend your money to for that return
so who is that well it's in their terms
of service there's only one approved
borrower of the Gemini earned money
Genesis Global Capital now Genesis
Global capital is a subsidiary of
digital currency group and an affiliate
of Genesis trading which we'll come to
in a moment but what does Genesis Global
cap Capital do with your money alongside
um Genesis trading well they lend it out
again and here's where we get to a
problem sometimes the people they lend
it out to it doesn't work so well
remember our video on three arrows
Capital the huge hedge fund that blew up
10 years ago I mean
I'm sorry uh blew up a few months ago
well three arrows Capital took out
billions in loans from none other than
Genesis who actually was their largest
lender with a 1.2 billion dollar claim
now their loan was partly collateralized
meaning they didn't lose the entire 1.2
billion that collateral was made up of a
lot of grayscale Bitcoin trust grayscale
ethereum trust and some other tokens
which Genesis basically all kept but
despite liquidating them they faced
hundreds of millions of dollars of
losses according to coindesk now around
that time Michael Morrow the CEO
announced that they had thoughtfully
mitigated our losses with a large
counterparty no client funds are
impacted translation we just got screwed
but we're trying to pretend nothing
happened I think it's interesting to
note actually that Michael Morrow is now
the ex CEO of Genesis and is now on
vacation according to his Twitter which
I gotta admit now on vacation is what I
would say if I were thoughtfully
mitigating the loss of my job but it
doesn't stop there because the parent
company of Genesis is called digital
currency group and they actually assumed
This 1.2 billion dollar claim supposedly
leaving Genesis with no outstanding
liabilities but not having that 1.2
billion dollar claim doesn't mean
suddenly they get their money back it
just means they don't have a 1.2 billion
dollar claim on their balance sheet
anymore it's now on Daddy's balance
sheet okay why does this matter well
it's important to the Financial Health
of Genesis because even the money they
did get back from three arrows Capital
the collateral may not have been
immediately sellable for example the
grayscale Bitcoin they liquidated as
collateral those assets are actually
part of another subsidiary of their
parent company digital currency group
called grayscale Bitcoin trust and I
know if it sounds confusing I'm trying
to make some graphics for this to make
it a little more clear either way this
is important because there are reasons
why if your Genesis or dcg digital
currency group you wouldn't want to sell
a bunch of a sister company shares for
cash because it would hurt your other
business especially at a time when
grayscale Bitcoin is already on life
support trading at a 40 percent discount
incidentally doing this trade is sort of
what got three Euros Capital liquidated
in the first place but that's another
story so it would deepen your losses if
you sell so what do you do well it looks
like genesis or dcg decided to hold on
to these grayscale Bitcoin trust shares
I guess in the hopes that they would go
up in the future and they may have even
bought more of them because based on
grayscale's 10q SEC filing it shows that
their parent company digital currency
group have been spending millions of
dollars buying up shares in grayscale
quote from March 10th 2021 through
September 30th 2022 dcg has purchased a
total of 771.8 million dollars worth of
shares in the trust all right what does
all of this mean well it means that
Genesis a giant lender of crypto got a
billion dollar hole they tried to push
on to Daddy when three hours capital win
under in return they got a few tokens
and shares in a sister company they
can't really sell and it looks like they
probably didn't sell because it's going
to make their other business do worse
not only that their parent company also
seems to have been dumping even more
money into these grayscale shares 771
million dollars worth and these funds
aren't exactly liquid because as I said
they're trading very low so the last
thing they're going to want to do is
sell these at a deep loss and now
finally we're going to get to the FTX
Alameda part of this story because
coming into fall season Genesis and dcg
like aren't looking great so this is
where we could be seeing the final straw
to break this whole thing although again
this is just my theory right because
everyone's panicking right now Bank runs
are happening everywhere and it might be
that Genesis just doesn't have the money
okay so here's the evidence on November
8th Genesis says of the FTX collapse
that they managed our lending book and
don't have any material net credit
exposure now to me this sounds a bit
like thoughtfully mitigating our law
losses but whatever pretty soon a day
later their story kind of changes they
say quote we hedged and sold collateral
resulting in a total loss of about seven
million dollars across all
counterparties including Alameda but
once again they insist everything's fine
right they say our exposure to FTX has
no impact on our ability to serve our
clients now the next day you might not
be surprised their story changes yet
again they say oops did we say we lost 7
million we meant that our derivatives
business has 175 million dollars in
locked funds in our FTX trading account
oops I guess uh they missed that one
guys you know sometimes I leave a
quarter in the couch sometimes Genesis
accidentally finds 175 million dollars
stuck in a bankrupt company it happens
guys it happens still though they claim
once again that quote our operating
capital and our net positions are not
material to our business okay now that
might be believable if the next day once
again something didn't change because
dcg announced that they were infusing
Genesis with with 140 million dollars
and naturally the question is is if your
business is totally unaffected by 175
million dollars going missing why do you
need to infuse that company with capital
and if you're trying to make sure
everyone thinks you're fine why not
completely replace the loss because as
some of you might have noticed you math
whiz kids out there 175 million dollars
is bigger than 140 million dollar
infusions so my theory well I think it's
because dear old dad the digital
currency group might not be so liquid
right now and I think Genesis is even
more in the whole now once again this is
speculation but it's based around facts
around genesis's already large losses
and dcg's nearly billion dollar purchase
of their own grayscale shares that they
can't easily sell I just don't believe
that they're doing that well right now
now of course could I be wrong could
they be completely liquid and have tons
of money extra yes absolutely would I
bet my money or your money on it no I
wouldn't hence the making of of this
video I just want you guys to be aware
of what's going on you can make your own
decisions with what you want to do but
if you're in the Gemini earned program
me personally I wouldn't be so
comfortable or if you're in a lending
platform where you're not sure if it's
related or they're lending out to
Genesis
um just be careful because you might be
at risk of contagion even if you think
you're fine now by the way I want to be
clear this whole thing is being
extremely charitable to dcg and Genesis
I feel like I'm doing free charity work
here because actually I'm taking them
very much at their word which I don't
believe is actually that reliable this
is when I'm saying that their losses are
truly as small as they say despite every
evidence seeming to suggest that
whenever possible they minimize their
losses take for instance their statement
about ftt this is of course the token of
FTX and it's nearly worthless now
Genesis said that they had no material
exposure to FDT or any other tokens
issued by centralized exchanges but we
basically know this not to be true or at
minimum is super disingenuous because
using the platform Arkham intelligence I
took a look at their books and found
that Genesis had a lot of ftt and was
actively receiving hundreds of millions
of dollars of ftt from Alameda as
recently as one month ago presumably in
exchange for loans and as recently as
one week ago they were sending huge
chunks of FDT not to FTX or Alameda but
to binance now why would they do that if
they were not selling now what does this
mean well Genesis obviously had exposure
to ftt from Alameda maybe in the
hundreds of millions of dollars so when
they're saying they didn't they're
either lying or trying to obfuscate the
fact that they sold them like last week
while the market was crashing with
everyone else but there's also this
whole dance in their language around
genesis's relationship with FTX and
Alameda in fact they say they have no
ongoing relationship but this may be the
greatest technical truth since I said I
appeared on a Netflix show because what
does no ongoing lending relationship
mean would you cut it off 10 seconds ago
like what is that obviously you lended
to them at some point and I attempted to
reach out to Genesis Global Genesis
trading and dcg for comment and here's
what they said about all this
anyways that concludes my video about
the Fallout of FTX and Genesis just
remember there's lots of people
pretending they're fine right now even
when they're actually very close to
bankruptcy so you need to stay safe out
there don't just take people at their
word when they say they have no exposure
to FTX or Alameda make sure you verify
okay thanks for watching bye